so i'm actually right now in talks with
coming out the book the end of next year
yeah so i'm working on that right now
end of next year means you bet you're
gonna have to get started i'm just
getting started in the last few weeks
yeah oh really so it's either gonna be
end of next year or maybe january at the
latest we're still figuring out
when it's going to come out but i'm i
mean i've been researching it in my mind
for years working on this but now it's
like okay let's make it happen
well
it'll be five years out
it's about the greatness mindset and
it's about eliminating self-doubt i
think self-doubt is the biggest killer
of dreams
i think there are three main fears that
we as human beings
have the fear of failure which a lot of
people have they're afraid to fail and
so they don't take action on what they
want or their goals or their dreams
because of that that insecurity or fear
around
what if i fail
the second big i never had that as an
athlete i don't think you ever had that
because as athletes we are trained well
you got to learn you got to make
mistakes every day to learn to get
better
to help you become successful and
accomplish your goals so i knew failure
was a part of the journey i'm like
practicing
to accomplish success and there's a
great
meme online i'm going to abbreviate what
the meme says because i can't remember
specifically
but there's a meme of a photo of a baby
walking or like trying to walk
and the quote or the meme says something
like
you know
children fall a thousand times before
they learn to walk
and never does the child think maybe
this walking thing isn't for me
i think i've seen that you know what i
mean it's like he doesn't the child
doesn't think oh yeah i felt 20 times i
scratched my face i you know my elbow's
bleeding i hit the back of my head maybe
i should just crawl the rest of my life
because i keep failing
and um i think you know once
the other two fears come into play
people are just afraid of failure the
second fear
which i never understood personally
because
i always wanted to accomplish my goals
was the fear of success
and when i when i speak or when i talk
to people and i ask them are you more
afraid of failure or success i'm always
surprised a lot of people say that
they're afraid of success
and again this didn't make sense to me
because i wanted to achieve i wanted to
succeed that's what i was going after
and
and i would ask people like why are you
afraid of success
and they would say something like well
the the pressure you know the pressure
that comes with success the weight you
have to carry
the idea that you have to live up to
something now like i've accomplished
this i have to keep doing this otherwise
then i'm a failure
um or
if i go and pursue my dreams
you know my family won't go with me or
they'll they'll kind of outcast me which
or my friends my peers you know i'll be
leaving the tribe the community
and i'm afraid to kind of lose my
friendships and be more alone or
independent so that fear of success is
strong for people those were never my
fears my fear was something else and
it's the third
uh the third fear which i think
a lot of people have as well which is
the fear of judgment
and
and criticism and other people's
opinions and
um i was never afraid of the failure
side because i knew as an athlete i
needed to make mistakes in order to
improve to get better to achieve i
always wanted to be successful so that
was not a fear of mine the pressure of
when i succeeded it was more just like
people's opinions of me or people
doubting me are people
criticizing me and judging me oh man i
lived that
right and so
at the core
you know usually someone has one of
those or maybe all those i'm the first
one right fair failure yep
yeah and so from and at the at the
center
so if you made it like a three-circle
venn diagram at the center
of
our fears is i'm not enough
of course that was totally my problem
that is totally my problem i yes it's a
dad wound yes exactly so i'm not about
to express it in the mom
yeah exactly and then the inner child is
always in pain and suffering so
i literally this has been this has been
a year of therapy for me i've done
therapy
every two weeks the entire year since
january and i am with you i had two
therapists at one point that i talked to
every week
yeah the first six months was like every
week like i was in couples therapy for
the first like five and a half months i
guess at least
it was every week it was like five seven
hours at a time on a day like we'd go on
saturdays and do it together
and it was it was so intense but as an
athlete
we uh we'll do whatever it takes you
know we're like i'm gonna keep trying
i'm gonna keep going whatever it takes
leave no regrets you know so
that was my mindset not even a single
letter
exactly yeah and i
and i said after
after i realized that in the previous
relationship that our our visions
weren't aligned and we weren't
uh a great match values and vision wise
i said you know what i'm going to keep
doing this i'm going to do this for the
rest of the year for myself
and see what that does for me and i have
this photo i don't know if you'll have
if this is a practice that one of your
therapists ever do with you
but i have this photo i have this photo
on my phone can you guess what this is
can you guess what this photo is that
i've had since
january i know maybe your inner child
see you as a kid
it's me as a kid i love you guys it's
just uh me and my dogs there you go yes
so this is a photo i've had
since since january
and my uh
and my therapist was like
listening and i said why do i keep
choosing specific types of relationships
now these not that these people are bad
and wrong not that you know
nothing just not the right match for me
and there was um
i kept doing it because i kept
abandoning myself i kept abandoning
myself on my values and my vision to
create peace and make someone else happy
as opposed to
being peace and healing that i am not
enough inner child wounds
to creating boundaries and then creating
from a place of standards and agreements
not i'm constantly having my agreements
broken by a partner
and giving in to try to make them happy
to create peace yeah and so it's been an
incredible year
of
reflection of getting feedback of
healing that and
and really diving back into again to
those three fears that a lot of people
have is
the core of any of those fears is i'm
not enough i'm not pretty enough not
talented enough smart enough whatever it
might be
and i think when when we learn to fully
accept
and heal what we've been through and
accept where we're at right now
there's a foundation that we can move
forward with a mindset we can move
forward with
that is a place of creation and pursuing
our uniqueness and our gifts in the
world and and putting ourselves out
there in a way that no matter we win or
lose people love us or hate us we do it
from a place of joy and a place of peace
because there's inner acceptance when i
when i had a i'm not sure did you know
kobe pretty well or did you interview
him
i only met him once i i forced my way
into an introduction at the espys one
time to say hi and that's cool
my my publicist at the time was the i
mean like he was a humongous fan and so
i i got him to say i like wanted to
introduce i met i introduced myself so
that i could introduce him um and uh
that's it though i didn't know yeah
i when i when i interviewed him i only
met him for you know an hour and um so
i'm not like i'm close with him or was
it close with them but
when i interviewed him
he said
when he was i can't remember if he was
12 or 13 but when he was like 12 or 13
he was playing basketball in a summer
league
and he didn't score one point he said
the entire summer it was like two or
three months he didn't score once
and it was somewhere around 10 11 12 or
something like that
and
i said what made you want to come back
and like after you failed miserably the
whole summer why did you want to come
back and play basketball again like the
next year or whatever
and he said i'm paraphrasing this but he
said
that my father told me that he's gonna
love me no matter what he's like i don't
care if you
score all the points or if you score no
points i'm gonna love you no matter what
and he said that gave him permission
to pursue something without one of those
fears without the fear of failure
without the fear of success and the fear
of judgment
and i think um
when we can learn to
love our own selves no matter what not
needing that from someone else or you
know whether it was your father or your
siblings or whatever it may be
for me it was peers you know being
judged by peers when i can when we can
learn to accept ourselves for who we are
and create from that space of inner love
and inner peace which is hard to do it's
hard to get there
that's when i feel like we can create
some amazing things in the world so
that's the premise of the book the
greatness mindset
that's really cool that's going to be a
really powerful book as they all are
from you
because it comes from your own
experiences yeah you know like when
you're speaking from pure experience
there's
there's depth there's emotion connected
to it there's truth and i think that
truth holds a frequency and so there's
an energy and a frequency within the
book and the writing that's that's
undeniable because it's not just a bunch
of words that you know we've heard a
million times written in a spiritual
book or written in like a self-help book
or a you know go get em kind of book
it's like your life on come to like
alive on the pages
um
i i don't know how come i mean you're a
pretty open guy but you we can we can
push the brakes anytime but i'm curious
because i think that this this idea that
i mean
i love that we're talking about
self-help and about looking in the self
and the inner child and the way that
things relate to our childhood and you
know it's something that i've been
working through for years now and i know
you've been working on for even longer
and you know i think giving some
examples and just talking through how
that goes because
there's i feel like there's so much
anxiety and so much stress in the world
and especially nowadays and it's like
maybe we can just sort of shed some
light from our own experiences just how
that looks and how that can show up in
our life and we can maybe learn how to
cope better because that inner peace
comes from making peace with those
things yourself so like what was sort of
the first
big hurdle that you came across or got
over
in therapy and and with the process of
therapy because sometimes my
breakthroughs came on my own but
maybe the impetus was a was it was a
therapy prompt or something to do with
it so like do you remember what the kind
of first thing was where you were like i
don't know
why i'm crying yeah yeah exactly i i
started my i would say i started my
healing journey eight years ago
yeah and where i started doing
therapeutic experiences workshops
therapies
that allowed me to start heal certain
parts of of the what joe dispenza says
the memories of the past because these
are memories that we
either amplify or diminish in our in our
thought and our memory so there's an
event that occurs
we have a memory of the event and we
either make it 20 times great more
grandiose than it was which is probably
what i do uh you know have done and you
know i went through this and this is how
it was but was it really how it was or
is that how our memory is
or we diminish certain things you know i
really didn't do this well or that
whatever it might be
and so for many years i've been doing
therapy experiences
and i talked about this publicly where
at the beginning it was healing the the
sexual abuse that i faced when i was a
kid which was really blocked inside of
my
body for 25 years i never told anyone
and that took
a couple of years of unwinding and
surrendering to and letting go and i
thought i'd done all the work you know
okay
isn't it always the case yeah then and
then i was like every couple of years
i'm like oh wait why am i still like
struggling with something so level new
devil exactly and i
and this time i was realizing that
sure i became a lot less reactive and
triggered in the real world
because i had healed something where
there had been abuse right i'd heal
something where there was a trauma so i
felt a lot less reactive whereas before
i turned 30 and started doing this work
i was very triggered and reactive person
i was a fun-loving guy but when i felt
under attack
um
like mentally and emotionally i would
react what triggered you
i mean
it was always the feeling of when
someone i when i felt someone was trying
to take advantage or abuse me it's like
abuse my generosity take advantage of me
use me for something
without like a good intention of just
like hey we're friends but they're
always trying to angle something or
abuse or
you know if it felt like that i'd be
felt triggered and i didn't know that
to the sexual abuse right sort of the
parallel later yeah being taken
advantage of when i was you know
five-year-old
and so
but i i still struggled in all my
intimate relationships like i was better
in business and friendships in the world
but still struggling in intimate
relationships
and i didn't know why and i kept
choosing
relationships again
all wonderful individuals i have nothing
better to say about them it's all my
responsibility of choosing
and abandoning certain things about my
vision
to make something try to work
and there was a moment in therapy
earlier in the year
where this has been a pattern in the
last decade from all the all the
relationships i've been in so this was
an earlier in the year this year yes yes
and there was a there was a pattern in
the last
probably every relationship i've been in
but i'm thinking of the last 10 12 years
of the the different intimate
relationships i've been in
there would always come to a point where
i'd feel a sense of like tightness and
pressure in my chest in every
relationship
and i feel more and more stress and
tightness and almost like kind of heart
palpitations at times
and this kind of like
underlying feeling of
trappedness and stress and and like
anxiety in my chest and always in my
chest and eventually go to my throat
and i didn't you know it's just kind of
like it wouldn't happen right away it
was like six to eight months in every
relationship i started to feel this and
then i would say
okay i'm an athlete
this is not going to fail i'm going to
make this work so
what can we what can i do how can i be
better how can i make you happy how can
i improve this relationship
let's go to therapy let's do this
together and i always thought this was
weird i always thought this was weird
that i would suggest therapy to every
past relationship and say i really want
to do therapy because i care about you i
care about us i love you i want to make
this work and something's not feeling
right
and they would all say no they don't
want therapy and i was like what i feel
like every woman would die if they're
born
right
yes and i was like come on like
this makes no sense to me you're like
the one woman and i kept choosing the
one woman that didn't want therapy and i
was like what
and um
anyways i realized i was i was dating
patterns and um again nothing wrong or
bad about it but it was it was a pattern
and this past
experience was the same thing for a year
i was like i really wanted to do therapy
i think it'd be important i remember
saying i would love for us to do therapy
in the beginning when things are good so
we just continue to like get things
cleared and we grow in a vision together
yeah
that wasn't the case and then
after a year of it ghana being up and
down right some good moments but then a
lot of like down moments
i remember just like we can't do this
anymore like this isn't going to last we
either need some support
or i don't know what we're going to do
because we're it's too up and down for
me it's not sustainable
and
finally you know after a year of asking
for this we finally were able to make
the therapy happen and
it was extremely profound for me
because it got me to have
someone with a different perspective see
the whole picture and it got me to talk
about these things and step back and be
like wow why why am i choosing to stay
in this why is keeping me motivated to
stay in this
and how can i take full responsibility
for why it's turning out this way
and there was a moment in therapy where
literally like the pain in my chest
came together and kind of disintegrated
into a ball into like peace and freedom
and like just disintegrated
and it was the weirdest thing
that i've ever felt because it felt
physical transformation in a moment i
had just like this awareness moment i
always used to feel like
i was trapped like i needed to make it
work and i could not end the
relationship there was no
i was not willing to end the
relationship so i would just stay in it
and keep trying to make someone else
happy
as opposed to
not abandon myself so what i realized is
that i was abandoning my inner child the
needs that i had over and over again for
someone else and i thought it was
unselfishness
as opposed to coming together into a
partnership with
here's who i am here's who you are do
you accept who i am right now
and do i accept who you are right now
and the partners that i was choosing to
be with never fully accepted me they
wanted me to change constantly and i
chose those relationships so i can't
blame them uh you know i don't i take
responsibility for staying in a
relationship where people wanted to
change me consistently
and i just chose that i want to keep the
peace so i'm going to do whatever it
takes to make this person happy
but they were never happy no matter how
much i changed and how much i did they
would always get upset at something
and that's when i realized like i don't
need to stay in relationships i can end
it and i'm not a bad person because i
always thought like if i end this i'm a
bad guy
i'm going to hurt someone and
you know what if they say something bad
about me and then
judgment so my thing was the fear
yes fear of judgment
and then i was just like
that was so held back by that fear of
well
what about the what if people think that
what if they say something that's not
true that i don't have control over
and then
people think i'm a bad guy or whatever
or my reputation whatever
and then i just got to a point where i
was like none of this pain is worth
anyone's opinion about me anymore
and i'd rather i'd rather feel free
and let people think whatever they want
to think
then be stuck and trapped in this
emotional um
relationship that i'm choosing to put
myself into no one's forcing me
and that
awareness
just gave me the sense of like peace
that i was like you know there's no
amount of abandoning myself that is
worth
worth it